[Music]  big  [Music]  where is it  because i'm old  i know it's cold i know i know yeah can  you give me your thing  i know baby come here i know baby come  here  [Music]  are you good with the with no light yeah  lincoln's  hey was the door unlocked yeah it's  unlocked  that would you check that it was  unlocked yeah okay and how do you guys  uh find out that there was a challenge  of this  car she came in and said hey there's a  baby in there and i don't know there's  another person there so we came and  check it out  yeah and then the moment that uh he said  hey  and then we start crying so i checked  the door and ended up and it was a  little bit open that's why i called  okay so you open the door and who's the  driver of this car  oh she's inside